>>> HOELLO, ERYBODY.
I'M JOHN KING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE KENNEDY
SPACE CENTER.
THIS IS AN HISTORIC FLIGHT WITH
TWO BIG FIRSTS.
AS WE LISTEN TO NASA, I WANT TO
BRING MARTIN SAVIDGE IN.
TWO IMPORTANT FIRSTS.
ONE OF THEM, A COSMONAUT ON
BOARD THE SPACECRAFT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 20 YEARS.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT.
SHE'S THE FIRST COSMONAUT AS YOU
POINT OUT TO FLY ON AN AMERICAN
FLIGHT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 20
YEARS AND THE FIRST TO FLY SINCE
THE TENSIONS WITH RUSSIA'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
YOU HAVE THE COMMANDER OF THE
FLIGHT, NICOLE MANN.
SHE'S THE FIRST FEMALE AND THE
FIRST NATIVE AMERICAN WOMAN AND
A COLONEL OF THE MARINE CORPS,
TEST PILOT, MECHANICAL ENGINEER,
AND SHE'S A MOTHER.
SO SHE HAS MANY, MANY ATTRIBUTES
THAT MAKE HER THE PERFECT
COMMANDER FOR THIS PARTICULAR
MISSION.
THEY GET SET FOR WHAT WILL BE A
LIFT-OFF RIGHT ABOUT 40 SECONDS
FROM NOW.
THE CAPSULE WHICH IS THE DRAGON
CAPSULE ON TOP OF THE FALCON 9
ROCKET SYSTEM.
WE'LL JUST LISTEN IN.
>> A REMINDER AS WE LISTEN IN
HERE, THIS IS THE USE OF NASA
NOW WITH COMMERCIAL SPACE
PARTNERS TO CARRY ASTRONAUTS.
THEY'LL CARRY ASTRONAUTS TO THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION.
LET'S WATCH.
>> T MINUS 15.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1,
MISSION, ENGINES FULL POWER, AND
LIFT-OFF.
>> 1 ALPHA.
>> COPY 1 ALPHA.
>> THE VEHICLE IS PITCHING
DOWNRANGE.
>> STAGE 1 PROPULSION.
>> APPARENT TELEMETRY.
>> STAGE 1.
>> MARTIN SAVIDGE AS WE WATCH
THIS TAKEOFF.
IT'S MAJESTIC.
I COULD WATCH IT OVER ANDOVER.
I'M A BIT OF A SPACE GEEK.
WALK THROUGH, AGAIN, THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS MISSION, AND,
AGAIN, THE COMMANDER, A NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMAN.
THAT'S A PRETTY HISTORIC THING.
A COSMONAUT ON AN AMERICAN
SPACECRAFT FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
20 YEARS.
AN IMPORTANT MISSION AND
REMARKABLE PICTURES.
>> IT IS BECAUSE OF THE
COMMITMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND RUSSIA DESPITE THE TENSIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED INTO
THE SPACE PROGRAM.
THEY NEED EACH OTHER.
AND AS A RESULT, THE
REINTEGRATION NOW OF HAVING
RUSSIANS FLY AN AMERICAN
SPACECRAFT IS AN IMPORTANT
MESSAGE.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, FOR NICOLE
MANN.
ASTRONAUTS ARE ALLOWED TO BRING
PERSONAL ITEMS WITH THEM.
COMMANDER MANN WAS ASKED WHAT
SHE WAS BRINGING.
SHE SAID AMONG PERSONAL ITEMS, A
GIFT THAT HER MOTHER GAVE HER
YEARS AGO.
IT'S A DREAM CATCHER.
THERE'S, OF COURSE, THE
IMMEDIATE CONNECTION TO THE
CULTURE SHE REPRESENTS, BUT ALSO
TO THE FACT DREAMS COME TRUE,
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT PROOF OF
THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT IS A REMARKABLE STORY.
MARTIN SAVIDGE, GRATEFUL FOR
THAT INSIGHT